packed with cooking tips information and
100 recipes to stay your life on take it
easy because it's time for my ultimate
slow cooking
[Music]
slow cooking is one of the best weapons
in the chess Arsenal not only is it easy
it's also an incredible way to transform
meat into mouth-waterly melting dishes
mastering the art of slow cooking is
something every cook should learn
first up my phenomenal slow-cooked beef
short ribs
slow cooking is a brilliant way of
getting lots of extra depth and
intensity into your dishes the secret is
to lock in all those flavors at the
start and let the ingredients do their
thing as it Cooks
these are beef short ribs and there's
basically five to six bones
across there and as the short rib Cooks
it sticks to that bone the bone implants
flavor and the meat just sort of melts
Cooks slowly gives it that nice level
intensity slice alongside the bone stray
down and see that marbling that sort of
disappears and disintegrates I'm cooking
them in a roasting tray get it on the
heat until nice and hot
seasoned beef short ribs beautifully
olive oil in both of the top we'll start
coloring that in
[Music]
it's really important to give the big
short ribs a really nice Sear
if you didn't Brown the meat off it goes
in the oven and it looks like boiled
meat so you really want that nice dark
Rich coloring
just cut the garlic
in half slide that down the side that's
going to give that beef an amazing
flavor
[Music]
to give body to the source stir in a
heap teaspoon of tomato puree I'm just
hitting the bottom of the pan
without tomato puree
and we call it cooking out that smell
the puree otherwise it just goes in
there raw and it gives this sort of
tartness to the braised short ribs red
wine in
don't use an expensive bottle of red
wine there's no need
bring the wine up to the boil and reduce
it this Burns off the alcohol and
concentrates the flavor it makes a big
difference when you reduce the red wine
down by half because it gives that nice
dark Rich intensity
look at my garlic that is just gonna
sweeten everything up incredible
stock in
beef stock perfect chicken stock fine
just to about an inch underneath the
beef short ribs bring it up to the ball
packing all that flavor as the beef ribs
slow cook cover them so they braise from
the bottom and steam from the top into
the oven two and a half hours
170 to 180 degrees
and she goes
the great thing about slow cooking is
you do most of the work in advance and
then put your feet up
five or ten minutes before the beef
short ribs come out of the oven start
your garnish this is light cured
pancetta
I want nice thick lardons
nice big thick sticks of crispy bacon
these are delicious Chestnut mushrooms
I'm not going to slice them
just going to cut them in half
look at the color on those loud ones now
all the white raw fat have disappeared
the larvans have shrunk right down and
all we've got there now is the proper
bacon mushrooms in
beautifully so the mushrooms get
seasoned from the bacon I'm pan frying
these separately to the beef so they're
main crisp another different texture
[Music]
leave that to cool down
now this is like Christmas day for me
when you unwrap that fall wait to see
what's underneath it
[Music]
hmm
wow
smell
incredible
lift
place
on your tray
beautiful
to make a fantastic Ridge deep sauce
press the soft roasted garlic through a
sieve into the cooking juices
we're all that nice pureed garlic coming
through there
because that is going to make the most
amazing flavor
scrape all that off the sieve
nice
then just start
saving all that lovely braising liquor
whoa
in
that smells delicious
take your sauce and just glaze
do them individually
they deserve that respect
spoon on your bacon and your mushrooms
beautiful
be generous with these mushrooms I'm
telling you they taste amazing
flat leaf parsley on that freshness over
those amazing ribs incredible never ever
be embarrassed about going to your
Butcher and asking for cheap Cuts
because the results
are incredible amazing beef braised
short ribs with bacon and mushrooms
mushrooms are one of my all-time
favorite ingredients
I use Chestnut mushrooms with the beef
short ribs because all of their firm
texture and nutty taste but there's a
huge range of other mushrooms that are
great for slow cooked dishes
and when it comes to buying them there's
one expert green grocer who's a Fountain
of Knowledge Burma Marcus Fred Foster
started off on the dead store in primary
coat really you had a salad stalk with
over 20 years of experience you could
actually write his own mushroom
encyclopedia
mushrooms as soon as you pick them the
moisture starts coming out of them so
you need to buy them when they're fresh
certain products you smell for flavor
and they tend to be fruits mushrooms
don't smell nice at all they smell kind
of metallic really
so you have to use your eyes as you
guide of what you buy with mushrooms
really really important wild mushrooms
are literally grown wild in the forests
they're just quality wherever they are
this is morel mushroom
a fantastic products so hard to find in
the world it's almost got an apricot
type of flavor earthy Woody and of
course as you cook it the flavor
increases for extra flavor and texture
highly prized morels are ideal when
added to slow cooked stews and
casseroles as are the trumpet de lemur
which have a deliciously rich flavor
another wild type to try is the
chanterelle its subtle fruity flavor is
delicious and perfect fried with butter
parsley and garlic when you're dealing
with wild mushrooms you need to clean
them it can be quite a slow process it's
with a soft brush don't don't use water
never use Woolworth mushrooms it
deteriorates the mushroom rapidly oyster
mushrooms are very meaty mushroom just a
lovely silky smooth flavor really nice
how do you tell whether it's fresh those
gills are bright never cut a noise the
mushroom always tear it look at the
whiteness of that beautiful that would
be gray if it was old although also
found wild oyster mushrooms are more
commonly cultivated along with similar
type the Enoki their delicate taste is
grain salads and soups
finally Fred saved the best until last
and of course the Pinnacle is the
Truffle they are really really short
after the smell is so intense that smell
it's it's hard to describe because it's
such a unique smell the more expensive
the Truffle the more intense the smell
so that's why you use such a small
amount on a dish it's amazing the way
they get these they used to use pigs of
course they don't do that anymore they
use Dog Steel because the pigs used to
eat them all this magical tasting fungi
is by weight one of the most expensive
Foods in the world it's phenomenal
eating raw shaved over pasta or risottos
or drizzle of truffle all Turns Slow
cooked stews into something out of this
world people are actually scared of
mushrooms aren't they so it's amazing
really they shouldn't be because take
away the fear and just close your eyes
and taste them they're just amazing
they're they are amazing
[Music]
cooking all the ingredients in one dish
helps to lock in taste and get great
flavors working together here are three
recipes that turn simple ingredients
into amazing dishes
first up a fantastically aromatic
melt-in-the-mouth treat pork neck curry
with mango salsa
[Music]
for the curry paste add chopped
lemongrass chili fresh ginger garlic and
Cafe Lime Leaf to a pestle and mortar
next put in aromatic ground cinnamon and
coriander
pinch of salt black pepper
[Music]
and Bash it into a rough paste
finally add olive oil to loosen and your
paste is done now onto the pork leg add
a lug of olive oil to a hot pan and
brown the diced meat carefully
making sure each side hits the heat
locking in that flavor
remove and in the same pan cook sliced
onions until Brown around the edges
at the curry paste and Fry to release
all the intense flavors
then put the pork back in along with the
coconut milk and stir
next add chicken stock palm sugar
more kaffir lime leaves soy sauce and
fish sauce to taste
then simply simmer for an hour
[Music]
slow cooked for succulents spicy super
easy to make and wonderful served with
fresh mango salsa pork neck Curry
foreign
recipe is
incredible spicy Szechuan chicken thighs
[Music]
first marinade the thighs with soy sauce
and shouting wine which is made from
fermented rice and tastes similar to dry
sherry
chicken thighs do a lot of work so they
need more cooking but cook properly
they're moist and they're the tastiest
part of the bird next add rice vinegar
water then season and leave to marinade
for up to two hours
then chop garlic
chili and Ginger
add olive oil to a hot pan and fry it
will softened add Szechuan peppercorns
and orange zest
next add the marinated chicken thighs
along with a marinade
and throw in a pinch of sugar and Fry
the chicken into as lovely and brown and
the sauce is deliciously thick
[Music]
finish with chopped spring onions add
lug of soy sauce and a few drops of
sesame seed oil
marinated for flavor sweet and spicy
chicken a fuss-free Wonder
[Music]
my final slow cooked dish that
transforms simple ingredients into
Unforgettable food is simple beef
brisket
[Music]
start by seizing the meat well
brisket is a cut of beef from the breast
it's inexpensive but it's fit for raw
tea with long slow cooking
Place into hot casserole dish with a
little olive oil and brown on all sides
[Music]
next make a tasty broth to flavor the
meat into the dish add chopped carrots
celery a whole bulb of garlic cut in
half peppercorns
aromatic cloves and freshly ground
nutmeg
pour in hot water to braise the brisket
bring to the boil and cover tightly then
transfer the dish to a low oven and cook
for three to four hours
cook low and slow the results are
amazing tender melt-in-the-mouth meat
fantastic with roast potatoes or in
sandwiches with lots of mustard but I
like it best with Tangy Piccadilly
in the oven in under 10 minutes then all
you have to do is sit back and wait so
easy and absolutely delicious what's not
to love about my succulent beef brisket
this is my ultimate cookery course 100
recipes to stay your life on soon I'll
be teaching you a wonderful slow cooked
dessert and look at the color on them
these smell
incredible
but first five more of my 100 tips to
make your home cooking easier
[Applause]
foreign
starting with how to cook duck breasts
perfectly the slow way
duck breasts never be scared about
cooking this bird absolutely delicious
very healthy first oven on 200 degrees
and then
salt pepper
now the salt will help to extract the
water out of the fat
nonstick pan no oil but start the duck
breasts in the pan cold
skin side down it feels and sounds a
little bit weird but if we put them into
a cold pan and turn the heat up
gradually it starts to release the fat
if we put them into a hot pan
it seals them in and the fat stays in
there we want to render that fat down 90
of that duck breast will be cooked on
its skin keeps the duck nice and moist
but more importantly it stays crispy
once the fat comes out turn the duck
over
nice high hot heat
seal the duck now they're going in the
oven skin side down 200 six to eight
minutes
if your Pan's got a plastic handle it
then transfer the duck breast onto a
tray but make sure you put the tray into
the oven to get hot first
cooking duck is like cooking a piece of
beef and you can't slice it piping hot
all the goodness Runs Out just quickly
turn it over
push your fingers in there and it's
slightly resistant but still quite
bouncy and that confirms they're quite
pink in the center but the important
part now is leaving that to rest let
them cool down
and then we'll slice them
keep that excess duck fats and there you
go next time you start taking potatoes
you just take them to a completely
different level now slicing the duck
just slice it at an angle not too thin
if you're slightly thinner it goes cold
quickly so nice thick slices
nice crispy skin on top
and a beautiful Clump roasted dark all
the white fat gone nice crispy skin and
absolutely delicious
another slow cooking tip is when slow
cooking stews and casseroles fat will
rise to the surface to get rid of any
excess oils my tip is to remove them
with kitchen paper before serving
this also works brilliantly on gravies
and sauces
many great slow cook dishes start by
Browning the meat as the meat Cooks lots
of flavors get stuck to the pan to get
it into your sauce deglaze with wine
stock or vinegar
never add soft herbs at the beginning of
slow cooking they're all too delicate
the tip is to add them at the end for
that Hill fresh flavor and vibrant color
a great tip when frying fish is to
always fry skin side down to keep it
crispy
and always lay the Footers away from you
when adding to the pan to prevent hot
oil from splashing towards you
[Music]
foreign
cooking isn't exclusive to just Savory
dishes it's a clever way to transform
fruit into wonderful desserts giving
them an amazing sticky Jammy intensity
invest a bit of patience and my next
recipe pays off big time
Indulgence and bursting with flavor
caramelized figs with ricotta slow
cooking can also take desserts to a
whole new level
a gentle long cook can really bring out
that wonderful Rich sticky sweetness and
that depth of flavor in fruits
these are black figs they are suited to
slow cooking roasting better than the
green figs because this outside skin is
so durable this is an amazing way of
roasting figs and it's so easy yet so
delicious lay your figs out in a rows
take some Rosemary and just peel that
down look at that really nice fragrant
stem get your scissors trim the edge
almost we've got a bit of a sort of
sharp Point bring your three figs
together
just thread the top of each fig
nice and gently Rosemary works
wonderfully with sweet dishes as the
figs roast in the oven the stock will
impart a lovely subtle flavor useful
dust the figs with icing sugar then coat
them with a generous splash of Blossom
with vinegar leave them to sit there for
five minutes they sort of marinate I
know it sounds odd to use vinegar in
your dessert but trust me it gives the
dish a fantastic sweet and sour taste
I'm going to make a really nice caramel
four or five tablespoons of sugar now
flatten that out and get it nice and
even when the sugar is even caramel
Cooks evenly
it's changing now you can see it melting
from the outside in the one thing you
don't do is shake the pan rapidly
and sit almost like sort of a lake
defrosting and it's hitting to the
center it's bubbling it's still not dark
enough yet
it's getting there
turn the gas down and stay in control
let the sugar melt until it turns a dark
amber color the secret behind any good
caramel is just stopping it from
overcooking
lovely
take that off the gas not with butter in
there
gently whisk in
the butter is cooling the camel down
you'll see it changing color to like a
cafe Olay
next add a lug of the balsamic vinegar
beautiful
for that nice dark richness
of a camel a little touch of water in
there
that way the camel doesn't go too thick
now put the camel back on the heat take
a fix and sort of place them in gently
lovely
and then just added all that lovely
little marinade
don't waste that
it's amazing stuff there
[Music]
icing sugar and Balsam and vinegar
so tasty
based those figs because the skin gets
nice and crispy on the outside and the
Fig sort of just absorbs the camel
delicious so easy
now into the oven
190 for 10 minutes
[Music]
almost doubled in size
now look at the color on them
they smell
is incredible onto your plate
they're a lot heavier because they've
actually started absorbing that camera
now dash the figs with caramel
and serve with ricotta cheese the
freshness of that ricotta goes
brilliantly well
with the figs
I'm gonna finish that now
it seems zest
and then
some little nibbed hormones
and the rich creamy Jam texture of the
Fig
with a ricotta
brilliant that is an amazing way of slow
roasting fruit
and taking figs to a completely new
level
[Music]
cookery course crammed with key lessons
top tips and 100 recipes to stag your
life on and you'll literally be cooking
yourself into a better Chef many of
these amazing recipes are on my app
please check out the app store for
details
go on get cooking now for the perfect
way to ease yourself into the day it's
my guide to brunches
[Music]
brunch is simply a delicious combination
of breakfast and lunch and for me it's
all about getting up late and having a
wonderful lazy start to the weekend with
fantastic food
more exciting than breakfast and a lot
more enjoyable to cook brunch is ideal
for sharing
first up my simple and delicious
frittata eggs are great they are so
versatile and once you've mastered how
to cook them trust me the door then
opens to a wide range of delicious
options
this is like a triple omelette but a lot
more ingredients than a normal mesh
let's start off with some lovely smoked
bacon slice the bacon bacon in
no salt
a little touch of pepper start off on a
high heat get our bacon really nice and
crispy otherwise you just boil the bacon
and it's got that soft unpleasant
texture in the frittata
go down the gas and now start adding
your veg roughly chop a red pepper and
add it to the pan
the peppers and the bacon take the
longest so they've always got to go in
first
now sucker them off
and the peppers have been cooked now
from that sort of rendered fat from the
bacon
and then
you spring onions just Bunch them up
slice them I want them on an angle
so they come like little green diamonds
spring onions in
now for the eggs
cracking the eggs
for that size pan
seven or eight eggs
I'm Gonna Fill it right to the very top
and more importantly when I turn this
out
I want it like a gateau nice and thick
so slice through and seal those
wonderful veg
[Music]
I'm gonna season the eggs
with some Parmesan cheese be quite
generous because it has a really nice
saltiness
[Music]
fresh ground pepper and then whisk
whisk up those eggs nicely
[Music]
then add peas to the pan
and to give the dish a wonderful
aromatic freshness some fragrant chopped
basil I want to chop that sort of
roughly
because I want to see those flecks of
green going in
white looking charming and how many
times have you seen a dull omelette
potatoes in my mind really help
encapsulate the magic of having
Savory eggs
cooked beautifully
but with texture now just before we had
the eggs
got this
beautiful little ghost cheese and it's
strong and powerful so I want to slice
it
into little chunks
and then just
have it dotted around I want to discover
these little pockets of creamy goat's
cheese now slowly
of the eggs
[Music]
fill that right up
and get your spoon now just let all that
egg go down to the bottom
bring it back up the boil
and sort of clean around the sides and
then some of this delicious salty
creamy ghost cheese over the top
and I want it melting like a
perfect slice
cheese on toast
nice now from there Turn The Grille on
for 45 minutes
[Music]
now
just looking at that
delicious
take a little paring knife and just make
sure it's released
from the sides
just take your panel
tap
that will hopefully release the frittata
from the bottom of the pan now
board over the pan
turn that gently
just
Shake say a little prayer and lift off
[Music]
now
from there
on there it's there look
now
slice
through
you can see how soft and creamy that is
in the center
and that goat cheese are just melting
almost like a little sauce inside so
exciting but more importantly it's so
easy to do it's got texture it's got
creaminess and that for me will beat any
omelette for brunch so with a stack of
hot buttered toast and a steaming pot of
coffee this easy potato Turns The Humble
egg into the perfect dish for kicking
off the weekend
foreign
versatile protein packed and delicious
here are three more of my favorite
recipes to give your brunches a tasty
twist
first up North African eggs
[Music]
add olive oil to a hot pan
and Fry finely chopped onions and red
and green peppers
[Music]
then chop garlic
and chili
and cook until softened
Chili's work brilliantly with eggs
giving the dish a lovely hot cake
next add fresh chopped tomatoes then
cumin seeds and Fry until the seeds are
fragrant and the tomatoes are lovely and
soft
next make wells in your spicy sauce and
crack in your eggs
then cover and cook on a low heat for
five minutes so the whites are set and
the yolks are still lovely and runny
to finish sliced spring onions
and coriander and simply sprinkle over
fresh spicy and deliciously different
easy North African eggs ready in under
20 minutes as this worth getting up late
for
next eggs made super indulgent for
brunch cheese souffle with three cheeses
[Music]
mix together flour
sugar
baking powder and seasoned
make it well in the center
then simply beat six eggs together pour
into the well and whisk into the flour
then whisk in the milk making the
mixture lovely and light next add the
three cheeses cottage cheese grated
monterey jack or cheddar
[Music]
cheese
and then for extra richness knobs of
butter
then butter a baking dish
pour in your Rich cheesy cheeks souffle
mix now put in a medium oven and bake
for 40 minutes until Rich golden and
puffed to Perfection
a stunning fuss-free souffle that's
ideal for brunch
[Music]
my next easy egg dish is a salty and
succulent prawn and feta omelette
[Music]
pour olive oil into a hot pan add
chopped tomatoes
spring onions and Fry
season
[Music]
next add cooked prawns and a Sprinkle of
chili flakes to give it a lovely kick of
heat cook through and set aside next
beat four eggs
add olive oil to your frying pan and
pour in the eggs
sprinkle on freshly chopped oregano
which works brilliantly with eggs
then spoon over the spicy prawns
crumple over creamy feta cheese and
grill for a couple of minutes
this is eggs to the nth degree packed
with different tastes textures and
flavors all working wonderfully together
perfect
one super versatile ingredient free
mouth-wateringly different recipes
brunch has never been better
nice
next my tricks the trade and kitchen
tips
first up red pepper as you've seen great
for frittata and North African eggs but
you need to know how to cut them
properly
I absolutely love these Peppers now they
have the most amazing sweet delicious
flavor with a really nice crunchy
texture and the most exciting thing
about the peppers is that they're just
as delicious raw or cooked to identify
the perfect pepper must be smooth and
firm and not a wrinkle inside now how to
cut the perfect pepper
stalk off
pepper down and get the knife start from
the top and slice all the way around
basically we're going to be slicing
around the seeds look no faffing around
like this little perfect Christmas tree
of seeds and you haven't got the mess
all over your board and more importantly
it's twice as quick discard that now
we're going to cut it into a julienne
flatten the pepper
skin side down onto the board because
it's a lot easier to slice through the
pepper and just lift the knife
up and down
and basically julienne is a chef word
strips
these are absolutely perfect for a
sewing and that's what we're looking for
there crunchy delicious and more
importantly
No Seeds beautiful
many great brunch recipes start with a
delicious fresh egg my tried and tested
way to tell if your egg is fresh is to
Simply place it into a bowl of cold
water a fresh egg will sink and a stale
one will float
if a small piece of shell goes into the
bowl when you're cracking eggs my tip
for removing it is to Simply use a
larger piece to fish it out it works
like magic
for prize-winning fried eggs fry them in
oil adding a tablespoon of water then
cover the water steams the top of the
egg to perfection
bagels are brilliant for brunch my tip
to make sure you always have them on
hand is to stock up your freezer but
make sure you slice them first that way
you can pop them straight into your
toaster
[Music]
this is my ultimate cookery course a
hundred recipes to stay your life on I'm
about to show you my recipe for
delicious spicy pancakes tuck it
underneath there pull it back and Roll
But first here's my guide to buying
beautiful eggs knowledge is crucial the
more you know about where your
ingredients are from and how they
produce the better
in my home kitchen I use eggs in
abundance they are so versatile and get
into grips with them or make your
cooking sing good girlies
chickens with a decade of experience
under her belt Helen from Harris Farm in
Hertfordshire is a real Egghead and has
some valuable tips to share
the hens we keep are designed to lay
probably
300 350 eggs a year
free range means that the bird must have
access to the outside at all times
chickens love grass they pick it
whatever's on the ground and it makes
the eggs a lovely Rich golden color and
the flavor is tremendous
tell if an egg is really fresh crack it
open put it on a dish and you'll see
that it sits up really quite High and
the white is really nice and tight
around the side of the yolk there's a
vast range of eggs out there to
experiment with why stick to what you
know try livening up your brunches with
something different this is a band Meg
they are Miniature chick
of the egg and they're absolutely
delicious making scrambled eggs off of
them because they're much more creamier
all together than
um say a chicken's egg this is the
duck's egg these ones are sort of an
off-white color but they can be sort of
creamy greeny colors compared to chicken
eggs the duck's yolk is richer and
creamier and the white is fluffier when
whisked which is why they're so
incredible for bacon this is the goose
egg this is quite a large egg it's
probably equivalent to three chicken
eggs the geese literally lay for about
12 weeks
from my few geese we've had about
120 eggs they're amazing layers but just
for the very short season the amazing
thing is the color of the yolks of these
they are usually quite orange the geese
don't actually eat anything other than
grass they are just grazes and that
makes a huge difference to the color of
the yolk
another fantastic egg is the quail egg
Tiny But incredibly tasty they only take
a minute to soft boil and a delicious
dipped in celery salt if you've got a
big appetite or you're making a brunch
for a big group of friends you could try
the giant rare egg from South America
the equivalent of 10 hen eggs they're
great scrambled or as a massive omelette
another interesting option is the
pheasant egg small but rich in flavor
they're perfect for homemade Scotch eggs
or hard-boiled in a salad you can keep
eggs in your fridge
um but ideally when you go to use them
take them out bring them up to room
temperature because you'll find that
they will cook better just make sure
that there's no cracks in them and then
you'll be assured that they're nice
healthy tasting eggs
[Music]
brunch should be a laid-back Affair and
a
and the dishes need to be easy to cook
but never boring
my next recipe takes the humble pancake
to a whole new level of flavor and
excitement
soft fiery and irresistible spicy
pancakes
one of the secrets to good cooking is
learning to use your imagination when it
comes to brunches you don't have to
stick to the old standbys these
delicious spicy pancakes are a really
great alternative but more importantly
so easy to do
start off by toasting your cumin
[Music]
it's a dry roast basically non-stick pan
just a touch of seasoning the salt helps
to dry out the cumin even more
and then fresh ginger slice them nice
and thinly
stack it back up and then just slice
nice little thin slices in there
and then keep that punched up
shake the chili
removing the seeds will prevent things
getting too hot now
it's garlic
nice now add olive oil to your toasted
cumin seeds and then with the garlic
ginger and chili lovely
and it feels strange when you talk about
garlic for breakfast but the time I
spent in India everybody was eating
something Savory for breakfast it was
extraordinary
set aside
next the pancake filling and olive oil
to a hot pan mustard seeds in now
they'll start dancing the minute they
hit the pan
then finely slice an onion
onions in
a little teaspoon of turmeric sprinkle
that in and I've got a color
an instant change leftover potatoes just
slice them
smell is incredible potatoes in now
spread the potatoes across the pan all
the potatoes stained I want them sort of
absorbing all that really nice turmeric
actually like a sponge
season those potatoes and it really
helps to bring out
spice beautifully
they're ready turn off the gas and let
them sit there and absorb all those
flavors back to the pancake batter add
plain flour to your cooled garlic chili
Ginger and cumin seeds Touch of salt and
pepper nothing worse than the Bland
pancake
one whole egg
milk hold The Jug one hand and whisk the
other secrets to get that really nice
smooth paste but whisking that egg first
and brings it together and then you're
milking
don't put all the milk in because then
you're gonna get a lumpy pancake mix
and if you put less milk in it really
helps it not going Lumpy
look at that
milky
the secret for me is to have a nice thin
mix well just
teaspoon
of oil that helps bring a nice crispy
Edge to the mixture now just taste
that's the texture pan on
the larger the pan the better it helps
to create the nice thin even surface I
want that mix going all the way around
the pan before you put the mixture into
the pan make sure you give your pancake
mix a really nice stir
pan it's nice and hot turn down the gas
Touch of olive oil in get that nice
whisk with one hand
pan to the mix in
one and a half ladles
and then roll it around it's just really
nice and thin I want to see the ginger
the garlic that's what I'm looking for
in there now back onto the heat it only
starts to remove from the bottom of the
pan and lifts itself up once it's cooked
these little bubbles confirm that it's
just starting to lift off the pan a
little shake that releases it and then
just shake it to the end
and toss if you haven't got the content
of tossing then use a spatula and turn
it over now that's exactly what I want
that nice sort of crisp edge around the
side the color on the pancake is so
important
now roll it around
just let it slide out
beautifully
now
for the exciting part filling them
take your potatoes just sort of
have a really nice imaginary line
and then just very carefully roll there
nice and tightly tuck it underneath
there
put it back and roll
pancakes are ready to eat but with a
simple dipping sauce there'll be a real
treat just mix chopped coriander with
natural yogurt
that's really nice cooling Asian sit
down on the side
for me is a great brunch delicious spicy
pancakes amazing
[Music]
My ultimate cookery course bursting with
valuable lessons
top tips and 100 recipes to take your
life on and you'll literally be cooking
yourself into a better Chef many of
these amazing recipes are on my app
please check out the app store for
details go on get cooking
foreign